[Musique]
José Legault Michel coje Chantal Hébert
bonsoir
on est quand même plus avancé on a un
chiffre depuis le temps qu'on en parle
est-ce que ce sera beaucoup passé
46,2 milliards sur dix ans d'argent
supplémentaires on voit le chiffre à
l'écran je vous fais rapidement attendre
ce qui était pas avec nous au début
d'émission monsieur Legault qui a dit
écoutez
on nous présentait comme une finale
c'est mieux que rien je suis pas content
mais on va le prendre on écoute
ce que j'ai compris de Monsieur Trudeau
c'est que c'était une offre pas mal
finale évidemment peu importe mon temps
même si les petits c'est bienvenu mais
effectivement c'est très loin de ce
qu'on a besoin à long terme pour
financer les soins de santé donc va
falloir avoir d'autres discussions avec
les gouvernements fédéraux qui seront là
avec les gouvernements fédéraux
autrement dit le sous-tex c'est avec
celui-là on est arrivé au bout de
l'exercice puis peut-être un jour on
reprendra j'osais le tour de table
d'abord José
mais comme si tu ne proposition
d'entendre sur 10 ans les prochains
gouvernements je sais pas s'ils
pourraient défaire ou pas c'est trop
trop là c'est c'est un peu ça m'a parlé
un peu risqué comme Paris
non c'est une combinaison qui est pas
nécessairement gagnante pour les
citoyens parce que non seulement il y a
pas beaucoup d'argent sur la table mais
en plus il y a aucune condition donc
peut-être qu'il va y avoir pas mal de
citoyens qui attendaient qui auraient
des conditions Keren reediction de
compte même si la santé est de
juridiction provinciale alors on verra
pour la suite Michel
sois sur l'extrait de monsieur Legault
soit sur de façon générale
46,2 est-ce que Monsieur Trudeau s'en
tire à bon compte
la question de non éditions de compte de
respect de la juridiction c'est quelque
chose qui demandait et qui est quand
même important pour le Québec pour les
autres provinces donc ça c'est une chose
d'autre part le taux d'augmentation le
taux d'indexation de la dépense qui va
être de 5% comme les provinces le
demandaient c'est important aussi mais
la somme globale n'est pas là c'est
évident et
c'est un fait que il y a un déficit
actuel aujourd'hui dans le financement
de la santé que le gouvernement fédéral
peut combler à seulement en toute petite
partie Chantal pendant qu'on voit des
images en direct monsieur Trudeau va un
jour venir s'adresser à ce micro là
Chantal
ouais bon ça s'appelle une offre mais en
fait ça ne doivent que le nom parce que
dans les fils le gouvernement fédéral
même pas besoin que ça soit avec les
premiers ministres pour dire on va
augmenter de transfert en santé de 5%
par année c'était venu un peu d'ailleurs
c'était dispensé d'une rencontre du même
genre pour dire voici ce que je vais
vous donner pour les années qui viennent
il va y avoir un plancher à trois pour
cent cela dit si l'argent réglait les
problèmes en santé on serait même pas en
train d'avoir cette conversation là
parce que entre 2000 cartes et 2014 15
16 les provinces ont reçu deux fois
l'inflation en augmentation du transfert
fédéral de santé en vertu de l'entente
négocie par Paul Martin et on est ici
aujourd'hui moi je savais qu'elle gagne
quelque chose de plus que ce que Michel
a dit c'est-à-dire pas de bâton dans les
roues pour faire ce que Monsieur Trudeau
a appelé des innovations et ce que
d'autres appellent de faire plus de
place au privé en santé parce que il y a
vraiment rien du genre là il y a pas
vous pouvez pas prendre l'argent puis de
mettre ailleurs ou vous pouvez pas
continuer à envoyer des services publics
au secteur privé donc on va laisser
clairement les provinces continuées à
expérimenter
l'autre personne qui doit être
satisfaite ce soir je pense monsieur
Trudeau après avoir eu de point de vue
de point de presse des premiers
ministres des provinces finalement ça a
bien été
si on avait su mais l'autre c'est Pierre
poilliers parce que là on engage pas un
éventuel gouvernement poignet à faire
plus que le 5% par année et
ça veut dire que ça lui donne ou ça
donne au futur gouvernement avec
lesquels monsieur Lego veut négocier un
jour peut-être
[Musique]
c'est à dire du point de vue des
citoyens qui sont aux prises avec des
systèmes de santé et particulièrement au
Québec qui sont très dysfonctionnelles
et Chantal raisons que l'argent ne règle
pas tout justement tout peut-être qu'il
y aurait eu nécessité d'avoir une
réduction de compte pas national un
petit peu plus importantes au-delà des
chicanes constitutionnellement je pense
au patients je pense au patients qui
n'ont plus patients justement et
l'éléphant dans la pièce c'est le privé
au Québec on sait il y a une
accélération du recours au privé qui
n'aide pas le régime public au contraire
les vampirisent le système public c'est
très bien là on ne met pas besoin de
donner l'exemple des infirmières dans
les agences privées les spécialistes qui
sont tellement difficiles à voir malgré
les énormes revenus qu'on leur donne qui
obligent de plus en plus de Québécois à
avoir recours à des spécialistes au
privé à très grand frais bon alors ça
c'est tout ça qui se profile derrière ça
et moi je pense que d'ici quelques
années il y a pas mal de monde qui
risque de déchanter et j'entends les
vous faisiez référence au thon et puis
monsieur Ford notamment qui a été assez
optimiste en disant vous savez faut voir
le vert à moitié plein
c'est de l'argent neuf même sur le goût
aussi que dire on va pas cracher sur de
l'argent donc tout ça indique quoi
est-ce que c'est la la fin de ces
grandes manœuvres on peut dire Michel et
chantant c'est la fin de ces grandes
manœuvres puis on verra un jour Michel
mais
on sait que ce sera pas suffisant pour
couvrir des besoins les besoins entre
autres en termes de médicaments c'est
cool augmente très rapidement en termes
de technologie ces couleurs et augmente
très rapidement puis la pénurie de s'en
ira pas donc les salaires vont augmenter
aussi alors c'est bien pour maintenant
un mois est défini ça dure combien de
temps ça maintenant je ne sais pas mais
ça c'est pas une solution à long terme
c'est pas ça va pas durer 10 ans cette
histoire-là
de l'agenda politique de même des
monsieur Poirier tout à l'heure cette
question là en disant bon mais ça a été
un peu comme l'avait fait l'entend avec
Monsieur Martin ça mène pas sur ces
discussions là
c'est selon moi la fin de cette ronde de
négociation ça veut pas dire qu'il y en
aura pas d'autres mais je vois pas après
avoir regardé le point de presse des
provinces je vois pas comment on vient
de ce point de caisse là en lion alors
que c'est un point de presse qui était
très très mouton
c'est
presque étonnamment parce que il aurait
pu être mouton en se disant on va amener
le troupeau plus loin sur la montagne et
monter le montant mais ils ont l'air
José déjà de dire c'est c'est pas
réaliste de penser qu'on va en avoir
beaucoup plus ça a été ça le message du
Premier ministre
si on rentre dans la bergerie finalement
et est-ce qu'on voit est-ce qu'on voit
derrière tout ça c'est c'est aussi une
espèce de
dilution du rapport de force aussi des
provinces face au gouvernement fédéral
lorsqu'on tient les cordons de la bourse
ben on décide de beaucoup de choses
finalement
et c'est toujours
oui mais c'est ça sauf que c'est
dans le passé c'était aussi la même
chose et il reste que faussé énorme
entre ce que le fédéral jadis
contribuait au système de santé des
provinces c'est-à-dire 50 % et
maintenant tout petit 22 % donc ça c'est
je veux pas compter les chemins fédéral
avec les points d'impôts que j'ai déjà
transférés eux les Sims 32 ok mais même
si je vous accorde même si je vous
accorde le 32 en 32 et 50
mineurs l'objet d'un débat
je vais vous parler parce que on sait
pas quand monsieur Trudeau arrivé va
arriver je veux absolument vous parler
c'est autre sujet qui est quand même
étonnant je vais vous montrer mesdames
et messieurs trois les trois visages des
députés du Parti libéral du Canada qui
le gouvernement issu du parti propose un
projet de loi pour renforcer le français
et l'ambre pulache député de
Saint-Laurent on va voir leurs photos à
inter de Mont-Royal et margarnaud qu'on
connaît ancien ministre Notre-Dame de
grâce-houissement trois côtés très rouge
ces trois députés là
font de l'obstruction ou demande des
changements à leur propre projet de loi
en comité et qui vient la rescousse des
libéraux dans ce comité-là ce sont les
conservateurs puis le Bloc québécois
quelques quelques extraits de la journée
parvient tout de suite vous écouter
en tant que gouvernement on a toujours
mis de l'avant une reconnaissance que
non seulement on doit protéger les deux
langues officielles à travers le pays on
doit particulièrement protéger le
français et particulièrement et même au
Québec c'est pour ça qu'on travaille
avec le gouvernement du Québec depuis
depuis longtemps on est en train
d'avancer avec la loi C13 qui non
seulement va protéger les communautés
linguistiques minoritaires à travers le
pays et qui va en sortir le Québec le
français au Québec aussi
c'est normal que ça soulève des passions
de part et d'autre mot pour moi pour moi
fondamentalement comme francophone je
veux vraiment
contiennent des garanties pour protéger
le français il le fait et il y a des
collègues
c'est normal que une fois je l'ai dit
tantôt
ok on va de l'avant et un autre libéral
qui est choqué contre les trois dont je
parlais Francis Drouin député de Glenn
où il y a beaucoup de francophones en
Ontario près d'Ottawa le shoot bouquin
mené par certaines mes collègues et
honteux le Montréal Island n'a pas le
monopole sur la politique linguistique
du Canada qu'est-ce qui arrive qu'est-ce
qui arrive Chantal dans le focus libéral
et pour ces trois députés bon d'abord
ces trois députés ont un certain nombre
de choses en commun ça commence par le
fait que aucun d'entre eux ne peut
aspirer à faire partie du conseil des
ministres monsieur Garneau on sait sur
la voie de garage depuis le dernier
remaniement et les deux autres sont des
candidats qui ont été imposés dans leur
circonscription par des militants
contre le choix de l'équipe de Justin
Trudeau alors comptez pas sur deux jours
où vous allez les voir en limousine
l'autre point commun qu'ils ont tous les
trois en présumant que Monsieur Garnaud
veut se représenter ce que je crois pas
c'est que même si les libéraux perdaient
misérablement
il serait toujours député à condition de
se présenter pour le parti libérale et
ça couvre depuis longtemps monsieur
Rodriguez c'est normal qu'il y a des
discussions non non non c'est pas normal
que ces discussions là se passent sur la
place publique en comité ou des députés
tendent demander le projet doit de leur
gouvernement qui est défendu quand le
Bloc québécois le MTD les conservateurs
aériens normal là-dedans il y a rien de
normal dans les insultes qu'on s'échange
sur les médias sociaux ce que ça veut
dire c'est ou bien juste un Trudeau
réussi à siffler la fin de la récréation
ou bien on va commencer à se poser des
sérieux questions sur sa capacité de
maintenir une certaine cohésion au sein
de son caucus trois députés José qui
estiment qu'on a fait trop qu'on en
ferait trop pour protéger le français
qu'estime que qui sont contre
l'utilisation de la clause dérogatoire
dans le club de la loi 96 donc pour
Monsieur Garnaud entre alors ils vont
ils tirent contre leur propre projet de
loi parce que il trouve que ça va c'est
trop positif pour les francophones
oui mais le point de vue de c'est de ces
augustes députés là est connu depuis
longtemps quand même là tout
particulièrement Madame lambropoulos et
Monsieur maintenir derrière Québec après
tout et donc des citoyens dans son
propre compte se plaint qui leur parle
pas souvent en français même si maîtrise
bien le français donc ça c'était connu
c'est pas une surprise là c'est pas
étonnant alors c'est deux choses l'une
alors où en effet la désorganisation est
installée dans le caucus et dans le
conseil des ministres parce qu'il faut
rappeler aussi que avec la nomination de
Madame el ghaouabi il y a des ministres
québécois seniors dont Monsieur de
Rodriguez qui était sorti aussi pour se
dire blessé etc par ses propos et où en
quelque part ça fait l'affaire de
Monsieur Trudeau qu'il y ait qu'il y ait
des député qui représente des
circonscriptions anglophones avec son
électeur c'est une partie de son
électorat qui est importante qui envoie
des signaux de d'inquiétude face à ce
qui se passe ça changera rien en bout de
piste sur ce qui va arriver mais ça
donne une voix à cette inquiétude puis
quand je dis inquiétude je devrais
peut-être dire colère même dans une
bonne partie de la communauté anglo
montréaliste donc c'est de deux choses
là
deux choses là-dessus d'abord
il y a beaucoup de désinformations qui
est véhiculée par ces gens-là y compris
la question qu'on pourra pas aller voir
son médecin il lui parle en anglais si
on le veut un moment donné il y a dans
une partie de la communauté anglophone
au Québec et supporté par certains
médias de la communauté agglophone
l'idée que si on aime pas quelque chose
comme la loi 96 c'est une atteinte à nos
droits c'est pas nécessairement le cas à
un moment donné on peut ne pas aimer les
lois ça fait partie du débat politique
ça c'est pas nécessairement une atteint
une atteinte au droit de la communauté
de la faute c'est la première des choses
la deuxième je suis en train de me dire
voici trois députés qui ne seront pas
ministres il y a pas grand chose depuis
dangereux dans un système parlementaire
qui est un député intelligent qui sait
qui sera pas ministre pour un premier
ministre c'est toujours difficile à
gérer et
Monsieur Trudeau de toute façon comme
premier ministre c'est quelqu'un qui
s'occupe pas beaucoup de son cocus c'est
connu ça maintenant il a la tête un peu
ailleurs et ces choses-là on viennent
toujours comme un Boeing dans
gouvernement si on s'en occupe pas c'est
pas qu'on connaît pas c'est ces trois
personnes là c'est peut-être un peu plus
surprenant monsieur Garnaud mais dans la
communauté anglophone le fait la
nouvelle politique de la notion de poser
leur madame jeudi mettez fin à
l'identité de traitement la minoritaire
avec quoi ce féminité à la fin
reconnaissait du
québecueil qui était en difficulté celle
que c'est le français
révolution pour eux en disant que le
français l'avantage menacé la José pire
que ça pire que ça qui va comme une
trahison de la part de Monsieur Trudeau
faut bien il faut bien comprendre ça là
Monsieur Trudeau il sait pas élevé
contre dans la loi 96 il y a une section
qui dérange beaucoup une bonne partie de
la communauté au Québécois c'est celle
aussi où on amende
unilatéralement le gouvernement du
Québec avant de l'unilatéralement à la
constitution 1867
une nation dans la seule langue
officielle et le français est-ce que je
peux vous dire que ça passe pas dans
et on lui aura passé beaucoup à Monsieur
Trudeau son silence là-dessus c'est pas
seulement la clause des rogatoire donc
moi j'ai l'impression et peut-être que
je me trompe mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on il y a des bonnes chances qu'on
assiste un peu à Bon Coin monsieur
Trudeau pas de Coop les trois députés en
question mais ça fait des ordres quand
même non ça fait des ordres
quelle est vraiment le coup politique à
payer pour ça c'est pour que le coup
politique on en parle depuis 10 minutes
mais pour que comment il s'appelle notre
ami de
Francis Drouet
il parle de honte c'est que ça montre le
malaise j'ai beaucoup de francophones
dans le caucus qui disent déjà on a pas
une bonne semaine la semaine dernière là
vous allez pas un comité si vous allez
en comité vous avez le droit de penser
ça comme député derrière banc mais à
l'époque enfin bref
à ce que je sache tout ça et cette forme
déplace vraiment et depuis des mois au
bureau du Premier ministre et ajustin
Trudeau qui
manifestement pas réussi à les calmer et
ça ça fait des mois que j'en entends
parler de la part de ministre qui sont
même pas québécois et qui disent on a un
problème puis on quoi faire avec alors
ça m'étonnerait beaucoup qu'on les
encourage sur cette voie là cela dit il
y a des gens aujourd'hui qui se
promènent dans les couloirs du parlement
qui disent mais au moins un code il
serait peut-être temps là dans le cas de
la député en question celle qui prétend
que on peut plus faire soigner par son
médecin en anglais il serait peut-être
temps de lui indiquer qu'une vie comme
député indépendante lui conviendrait ce
qui est sûr que ça non réélection
prochain sculpteur parce qu'on se
souvient vous l'avez dit je sais pas qui
voulait dire tout à l'heure j'entends
José c'est Madame lambropoulos n'était
pas le choix de Monsieur Trudeau c'est
Yolande James choix réinvestiture il y
avait mis la la machine puis c'est
Madame qu'on ne connaissait pas mais
qu'on connaissait mais moins disons que
remporté l'investisseur ok alors
pardon oui José
ouais mais je continue quand même à
penser que c'est le premier ministre du
Canada il y a une ligne de partie une
ligne de caucus écouter il y a des
députés qui ont été disciplinés dans
d'autres gouvernements pour beaucoup
moins que ça alors
en quelque part moi je continue à penser
que ça donne une voix à une partie de
son électeur un peu comme Steven Harper
qui laissait certains de ses députés là
rêver de limiter le droit à l'avortement
tout en disant non non j'y toucherai
jamais c'est bon alors des fois comme un
presto vous êtes on fait sortir la
vapeur un peu pour calmer ça
l'encourager on laisse pas
déchirant sur la place publique
vous avez oublié la santé monsieur
Trudeau devait parler il est très 17h38
est-ce qu'on a encore l'image du lutin
en question alors c'est comme ça ça fait
par ça c'est comme l'impôt et la mort
c'est des certitudes il y a des retards
car monsieur Trudeau est d'autres
premiers ministres il faut dire mais
monsieur Trudeau ça lui colle à la peau
un peu là faut dire qu'il y a une
rencontre Monsieur Duclos devait donner
des entrevues mais tout ça retardé alors
bref on va on va on va vous donner en
direct
cette histoire là mais je vais pendant
que je vais profiter de vous pour un
autre sujet qui était connexe à la santé
ça va nous permettre de parler quand
même un peu de la partiel qui a été
déclenchée dans l'ancien comté de Madame
Anglade
c'est un risque intense vous voyez cette
affiche
monsieur Legault baisse d'impôts qui ont
été promises en campagne électorale ça
non plus j'ose Espagne surpris mais la
journée où il est à taïwa pour plus
d'argent pour mettre un système de santé
est-ce que est-ce que faire un lien
c'est tendancieux José je commence avec
vous tour de table oui c'est de la
misère à la regarder je m'excuse
tellement
c'est sûr on a l'impression que c'est
Monsieur baisse d'impôts est-ce que
c'est son nom c'est pas oui il y a ça
mais ça c'est le problème que Monsieur
LEGO avec Monsieur Trudeau depuis le
début sur ce sujet là il baisse les
impôts d'une main puis de l'autre il
demande plus d'argent en santé
mais pour une partiel j'avoue bon je
referai pas la blague tout le monde l'a
fait depuis ce matin là ça rappelle la
télécérides du Plessis Maurice Duplessis
donne à sa province etc
mais c'est sûr que dans ce côté-là bon
c'est pas qui veulent l'emporter mais
c'est c'est d'un goût douteux disons-le
comme ça
non seulement c'est douteux mais ça
vient confirmer en fait que la carte
pourrait changer de nom et s'appeler le
parti François Legault que ce serait
pareil je sais pas si les les affiches
ont été faites avant qu'on désigne le
candidats
ou si c'est autrement mais je dirais la
fin c'est parti là c'est François
Legault alors pourquoi pas mettre cette
photo directement et puis le siège aussi
c'est le désir on voit le candidat là
j'ai dit la carte
de Montréal je pense sérieux François
Legault en gros plan c'est pas si
vendeur que ça
on peut avoir l'impression qu'on s'est
trompé d'endroit pour installer ses aff
iches à d'autres régions où ce serait
plus vendeur et baisse d'impôts sur
l'île de Montréal alors qu'ils question
de transport en commun dans
environnement de turbain
c'est pas non plus particulièrement
vendeur l'impression que ça donne c'est
on a recyclé une photo du chef suprême
et puis on va faire campagne comme ça
pour se rendre au traitement et le 13
mars
on espère que c'est pas mécanique qui a
conseillé ça quand même
c'est terminé c'est fini Michel vous
aviez dit c'est son rendu toxiques chez
certains mais en tout cas avoir
non mais un petit mot sur la partiel
quand même ça va être intéressant parce
que Québec solidaire doit remporter ça
José là
qui se représente qui est connu avocat
qui connaît bien toutes les questions
évidemment lui il peut pas perdre ça va
être lui quand les libéraux non
c'est le net à deux là à moins qu'on est
vraiment une surprise mais oui et pour
Québec solidaire c'est très très
important de remporter ce compte-là
premièrement ça va les amener à 12
députés quand même ce qui est important
comme c'était pour leur statut mais
c'est aussi qui
ayant mené une campagne disons qu'un k
n'ayant pas eu le résultat qu'ils
escomptaient si en plus il devait ne pas
remporter cette partie là alors que le
Parti libéral du Québec est dans le 36e
dessous là dans toutes les tranches à
peu près de l'électorat ce serait quand
même quelque chose tandis que pour le
Parti libéral du Québec pour martanguy
son chef intérimaire je pense que il y a
pas beaucoup d'attente là je veux dire
si le PLQ remportait cette partiel là ça
serait mon dieu des bouteilles de
champagne s'ouvriraient pas montrer leur
à tous
donc les vrais s'attendent sont envers
Québec solidaire ça c'est
populaire c'est important de montrer que
même si ces résultats étaient
descendants puis soyons clairs à
l'intérieur à Québec solidaire ils ont
pas été ça va ils ont été très décevants
que on est capable de rebondir c'est la
première étape de de recommencer avoir
des choses de façon un peu plus positive
et ils ont vraiment besoin de ça puis
c'est pas gagné d'avance c'est un côté
où il y a quand même un nombre élevé
d'anglophone c'est aussi du même les
francophones de ce côté-là sont plutôt
plus à l'aise plus susceptibles de voter
libérale c'est que le fait de temps
maintenant c'est toujours sans compter
qu'il y a beaucoup changé alors il y a
un petit côté bois de surprise ok
Chantal conclusion
et la première avantage s'ils sont
capables c'est de prouver qu'ils ont des
troupes sur le terrain parce que dans
une partiel la participation est basse
et dans l'état du Parti libéral
actuellement sortir de votre libérale ça
risque d'être laquelle la bannière donc
si ils sont pas capables de s'imposer
dans ces conditions-là ça va un peu
confirmer
[Musique]
l'élan qui c'est pas manifesté au
scrutin de l'automne dernier ok alors je
conclus je vais vous donner un dernier
mot dernier tour de table avant de se
quitter sur le chiffre de la journée
quand même 46 on peut voir le tableau
46,2 milliards le fédéral plaide qu'il
donne déjà beaucoup là il donne au total
ils disent on aura donné dans 10 ans 96
milliards 186 milliards 200 milliards
sur 10 ans mais ce qu'on ajoute sur la
table qui est nouveau c'est vraiment ce
chiffre là
46,2 ce qui comprend une indexation de
5% automatique donc seul prévisibilité
les promesses ont gagné ça ils ont gagné
l'absence de conditions le montant est
loin des rêves parce que je pense
eux-mêmes le savait en privé ils
allaient pas avoir 28 milliards la
première année de plus je pense que ça
c'est un peu on était dans nos rêves les
plus fous mais
on est malgré tout déçus du 46,2 mais
c'est de l'argent nouveau on a compris
José Michel et Chantal qui aura pas de
déchirage de chemise ils vont prendre
les l'argent nouveau puis ils vont
continuer à plaider c'est ce qu'on
comprend à tour de table je pensais que
vous Chantal
on comprend aussi qu'il va y avoir des
grands débats au niveau provincial sur
la réorganisation de la santé et de la
place du privé en santé et que ça va se
jouer dans l'urne mais pas dans l'urne
fédérale dans l'urne au niveau des
provinces ça va commencer par l'Alberta
au mois de mai oui
la première ministre de l'Alberta waouh
Michel C
4,6 milliards par année sur 10 ans mais
c'est un gros chiffre mais c'est pas un
gros chiffre annuellement c'est loin
d'être suffisant objectivement pour les
besoins actuellement on verra comment
dans deux ou trois ans le pèlerinage se
refera une autre fois Ottawa pour dire
on a encore des problèmes José
ouais c'est ça moi ma crainte c'est que
le privé va continuer à prendre de plus
en plus de place on va ajouter des
vitesses à un système de santé Canada au
moins deux et donc qui créent des
iniquités importantes dans les sociétés
et ce qu'on oublie aussi dans cette
liste de priorités qu'on s'assuelle ben
on est dans une population très
vieillissante puis il y a des soins de
longue durée il y a des soins à domicile
il y a des besoins sont
exponentiels en plus de la
réorganisation bien entendu donc
c'est ouais c'est pas c'est pas Noël
c'est pas Noël j'ai un peu de temps
parce que vous avez compris que mes
résultats
et José vous avez dit tout à l'heure
quelque chose parce que bon c'est pas un
secret là José vous êtes vous êtes
souveraineté vous êtes nationaliste et
vous avez dit moi comme citoyenne ça
m'aurait pas déplu que le fédéral
créer certaines obligations dans
certains domaines où resserre la vie au
privé vous ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle
communément des conditions donc vous
auriez pas sauté Patrice le seul East
dont je me réclame c'est journaliste
donc
les gens maintenant
c'est correct mais pour moi je prends
aussi le point de vue du citoyen le
point de vue du citoyen qui est très en
demande de soins de santé et de services
sociaux aussi qu'on oublie que c'est la
même enveloppe santé service sociaux
encore une fois dans une société
vieillissante et moi ce que je crains
puis je suis pas la seule il y a
beaucoup de spécialistes qui craignent
aussi c'est que sans condition bien on
va justement aller de plus en plus vers
le privé puis la réduction de compte
devant les lectorats c'est très limité
ça et au Québec aussi ça a été très
limité parce que parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont juste
démissionné de ça qui sont devenus comme
fatalisent ça va jamais s'améliorer etc
alors est-ce que les gouvernements
payent vraiment dans l'isoloir pour ce
qu'ils font au système de santé au
Québec depuis 30 ans mais vous seriez
allé plus loin être avoir été Justin
Trudeau vous seriez allé plus loin dans
les exigences aux provinces
ben oui toutes les provinces je pense
que ça aurait été nécessaire pas des pas
des pas des menottes mais pour écouter
le Canada c'est quand même un pays c'est
sabot est une juridiction provinciale
c'est quand même inquiétant qu'on n'est
pas droit à des services semblables ou
similaires à travers le Canada qui est
autant de disparité alors je laisse la
parole à Monsieur Trudeau
puis c'était pas je disais pas que vous
étiez là je disais que votre histoire
comprenez-vous que parce que c'est les
grands courants de penser que les
conditions les champs de juridiction
tout ça j'allais plus là mais oui Michel
vas-y oui oui
[Musique]
quelque part
ça c'est pas parti avec ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui mais elle mais à la
fin
c'est le montant qui est passé au puis
on en sorte mesdames et messieurs merci
beaucoup José Michel Chantal pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI